[Music]
some therapist
good geniuses thanks for that are
recommending a rage room or a smash room
when it comes to kids it can be a fun
and safe activity but kids aren't
allowed to use glass or heavy duty tools
like sledge hammers only adults throwing
temper tantrums can do that here's the
thing
[Music]
here ye hairy it's john with the dr john
dalone's show
just yanked us back out of the 1500s for
a minute that's where kelly likes to
live her and her romance novels we're so
glad you're here we're talking about
mental health relationships i don't
even kelly's more of a murder podcast
kind of gal not a romance novel kind of
gal are you a romance noveler
no although
15th century british
[Applause]
history
but not romance novels that's not really
my thing that's your thing
well i'm gonna from this point forward
get you some romance novels because i
think it's time i think it's time to
come back from the edge of murder
speaking of murder dude
can we just put an end to this uh kelly
gave me these
this article here
here's what it said abc action news
because all news is action
just got out of a relationship had a bad
day at work or are you stressed and need
to release without hurting yourself
someone else or damaging your property
so
are you a grown-up who is in desperate
need of a childhood temper tantrum to
kick your little feet and to cuddle up
with your blankie and to be met
some therapist
good geniuses thanks for that maybe you
should have read one or two textbooks in
grad school are recommending a rage room
or a smash room
a temper tantrum room a
pee in my pants and poo poo in my diaper
room
starting to pop up across the country
i won't even read the names it's a
release a different form of expression
anytime somebody says
it's a form of expression hemorrhoids i
get instant hemorrhoids i go straight to
the preparation age aisle it's just a
form of expression
oh gosh people coming in nurses teachers
they do it for a quick 15 minutes sit
down and relax afterwards and then go on
with their day
so many different aspects of how great
spending 15 to 20 minutes in a rage room
can help you feel
and when it comes to kit oh good let's
bring our kids along this will be fun
thanks thanks parents thanks adults
when it comes to kids it can be a fun
and safe activity
kids love it we have at least two
birthdays a week here
but kids aren't allowed to use glass or
heavy duty tools like sledgehammers only
adults throwing temper tantrums can do
that here's the thing
that
this gets me so frustrated
listen
your body doesn't work that way
what behaviors you choose
on the heels of feelings what behaviors
you choose on the heels of an emotion
encodes itself into your body and
becomes your default response
it's called neuroscience and i'm not
even a neuroscientist i'm a podcaster
and i know this
okay
what you do afterwards when you get
angry when you get frustrated when you
get sad when you get um um
when you have a boo-boo in your diaper
and you're a grown whatever
what you choose to do next becomes your
default mechanisms your body outsources
it to automated response
so
if you get angry
or tired and you go pay somebody money
to smash something with a hammer
to
to
crush glass to do tough things
your body will begin to automate an
angry violent response to those things
it's just the way our bodies work
right this idea it's this old pressure
cooker model it's not real it's not real
that i just have to quote unquote get my
anger out no
you don't
when your fight or flight when your
stress hormones kick up when your stress
chemicals if you will pulse through your
body like adrenaline cortisol those
things
channeling them towards rage channeling
them towards i think what rage is but
channeling them towards anger towards
frustration towards you
just makes it that much easier for your
body to default there the next time and
the time after that and the time after
that and the time after that and by the
way you teach your kids that and they
grow up defaulting to that defaulting to
that defaulting to that
don't
stop when you get frustrated
feel it
sit in it for a minute
say the words out loud with a
sigh i'm frustrated i'm real frustrated
right now when you get angry all anger
is is a is a
physiological response pointing you
towards something you care about
i'm really pissed off i'm really angry
right now
because she's not supposed to treat him
that way
because my teacher is supposed to my
son's teacher is supposed to care a
little bit more about him
because the guy i hired with money i
don't really have to mow the lawn did a
crappy job that guy cut me off in
traffic and i'm not about to die
on the heels of a little square kia
who's driving like a maniac because
they're texting
say the things out loud and let your
body feel them
go for a walk
go for a run
let that be your default mechanism
grab a pen and a paper and write them
down i am really angry because
getting your car and seeing 80s metal
tunes as loud as you can or whatever
nonsensical pop tunes on i don't know
what's in your head
train your body
to respond in productive ways in healthy
ways
and in
neuropsychologically com compatible ways
with overall well-being and health
rage rooms
listen i had a buddy growing up and we
would get stuff and smash it that's a
blast if we want to have smash rooms i'm
all for it like we can be mario brothers
but by calling them rage rooms but i
think we're solving things what we're
doing is we're just
tightening up the trigger towards an a
like an angry response towards a
response we're not gonna be able to get
back towards saying the thing screaming
our lungs out to throwing a temper
tantrum stop
we are too stressed too fried too
exhausted too burnt out as a culture
to create
these pathological responses as quote
unquote solutions they're not they're
not
a walk is
a long long journal entry is how tough
is that
you can have a journal room
that'd be the lamest business ever come
to my journal room and write down your
whatever do something positive hey
here's a crazy idea call somebody that
you care about and say hey i don't need
your solutions i don't need your advice
i just need to vent for a minute i'm
going to talk to you because i trust you
here we go do that
and then when you get angry when you get
frustrated and you get sad and you get
overwhelmed your body will begin to look
for people to reach out to
and other people are one of the
cornerstones of psychological well-being
control autonomy is one of the core
functions of psychological well-being
not smashing everything and yelling and
scream
so there we go america that's what we
need temper tantrum rooms
all right that's enough of that let's go
to samuel in atlanta hope you're gonna
not be angry samuel what's up man
hey doctor john sorry you have to
fantastic
all right so what's up dude
all right so
admittedly
i have a good problem
you are the perfect call following my
little wet diaper routine i just did so
what's up
all right so
i'll start off with a question and then
i'll give you some background
information cool so
essentially
i got a
awesome job offer that would give me a
huge bump in pay
and it'd be amazing for my career
but
it would probably
double my working hours to be like 70 or
80 hours a week for the foreseeable
future yeah and
i'm kind of not sure if it's worth my
sanity
so that's the question background
information i'm 25 years old
i work at
one of the biggest finance companies on
the planet okay
and i've been with the same company
since i graduated college okay
uh
in my free time the time that i would be
basically selling to the company
i'm not doing non-productive stuff like
i'm not just sitting around watching tv
i have a couple of entrepreneurial
ventures i'm engaged in and
you know so that's kind of there's like
a financial component but it's more
about the mental health is really why
i'm calling i don't want to burn out at
25. cool so you equated
70 80 hour weeks with
um your mental health so what's the min
what
so if you double your salary let's say
and
you go do this and it's
i it's this is an uh a well-kept secret
especially to those in their early 20s
into into about 30.
that those who make a lot of money earn
a lot of money they work really really
hard and they work a lot and they're
always thinking about it right so
there's a correlation there that i
didn't even get until i was out of
school it's like oh man that guy makes
six figures but he earns six figures
that sucks right i thought they just
gave it to you and so
you're equating a lack of sanity with
80-hour weeks 70-hour weeks tell me more
about that
um i'm kind of just assuming that's
going to be the case so a little bit
more background the reason why this
promotion opportunity opened up
is because a bunch of people quit yep
so
you know i got to think and i've talked
to some of the people that left and
basically
you know it's gonna be
really demanding it's gonna be
probably eight to eight plus some
weekends
and there's not really
a break you know i i like waking up on
saturday morning and you know drinking
coffee or going out in the sun or
whatever but
if i'm going to be waking up on saturday
and opening up my laptop waking up on
sunday of like i envision i'm not going
to have time to breathe and take a break
and do the other things that actually
fulfill me and make me happy sure
so i'll tell you there is no job worth
your sanity okay
it's just not worth the money i've spent
too much time with people who have
earned money that i will never ever earn
who've accumulated a lot and
have hollow lives okay so
that equation doesn't work
what's given me pause about your
situation
is the other side which is are you
married
no i'm single okay
if there's a season to get so far ahead
financially
experientially and this sounds like a
job that they there's there's kind of a
grist mill
we know we're gonna run people through
it they're gonna stay for two to five
years until they get something better
and they're gonna use our name to go get
something better in our experience and
we're to extrapolate every last bit of
blood out of them while they're here
there's almost a handshake agreement
we're going to pay you a ton of money
and we're going to take your soul from
you
and you're going to do it for a finite
amount of time so my question to you is
this
because i'm hearing
this
i'm all for take care of yourself i'm
i'm number one i'm also all for in your
20s especially with unmarried without
kids
work the 80-hour weeks and make double
the salary for two three four years
grind it learn everything you can from
everybody you can
all the new clients figure out what
they're doing and why they're doing
and then all of a sudden you're going to
open your eyes you'll be 28 and you're
going to go be able you're going to be
married and you're going to go find
balance and or more of a a life that's
more uh the balance is kind of a myth
but
you're going to lean more into a
stability right
and you're gonna have
made eight years worth of salary in
those four years
see what i'm saying
yeah yeah that's kind of where i'm
leaning too it's like you know
i know that money will be great in the
short term and the work will be awful in
the short term but
the long-term implications of me being
25 making the salary i would make
are
huge like you know i'm thinking about
the next 20 years worth of earnings like
i'll probably never make less than this
and
eventually like you're saying i'll be
able to afford to take a year off from
work as a whole and you know do whatever
i want or whatever the case so well
i don't want to build up to like i don't
want to like kill myself for a decade so
that i can do nothing in the year 11
right um well right i know what you're
saying here's another uh falsity if you
will
you can set boundaries
and
some people don't
and they blame the company
some that don't exist and that's fair
and true i know that that exists people
expect your soul from you
but in most jobs most of the time you
can set boundaries
and
i don't open my laptop up before x and
i'd close it at y and i don't take phone
calls on not everybody but most of the
time the boundaries we don't set is
because we want to
be the star employee we want to go all
in we want to
and i man most of the time it's been one
time in my career when i said um to a
supervisor so are you asking me x and
they said yes
right and then i had a decision to make
but most of the time it's about setting
good boundaries
and
that might be wishful thinking on my
part dude
um
but like that i mean there's definitely
you know i could set some reasonable
boundaries yeah but
i'm not exactly on my own timeline
either so what does that mean i know
what you're saying
well and maybe for the next three four
years you give up on your
entrepreneurial things or you say i
would never give up on the
entrepreneurial things
and i hope that in three or four years
they're making this salary
right right it's both hand so it really
comes down to a finite amount of time
i'm not in favor of doing this for a
long time i would not be in favor of
this if you're married i wouldn't be in
favor of this if you had kids and i know
that's a i don't know some kind of iss
statement a gender disturb not a gender
because i don't care if you're a male or
female but
i'm treating you differently because
you're single how about that but what
i'm saying is you have an opportunity
that you might not have otherwise
my wife and i did something very similar
with grad school
we worked full-time jobs and then we
were full-time grad students all the way
through our phd program so we worked
full-time jobs
and sometimes two jobs and we were both
in grad school
and so we did that and it was
six a.m to eight or nine to ten o'clock
at night for years on end
but i got to where i loved the work she
was much better at boundaries than i was
and so her journey was much more
pleasurable than mine was i was a maniac
and
i ended up completely cooked
but
it allowed me
when i hit my 30s and we had kids and it
allowed me a whole different life
because i put in that hard grind out at
the beginning you know what i mean
yeah
so that that's my journey man i can't
make that call for you
um you and only you know what the work
is going to be i don't even know what
the work is man and if it's just staring
at spreadsheets all day in the dark or
is it something you can take your laptop
i wrote most of my new book out on my
front porch i just moved a desk because
i knew i couldn't be inside for the
hours it was going to take to do this
and so i would sit outside sometimes in
the pitch black in the middle of the
night riding on my front porch sometimes
in the early morning when it was
beautiful and sunny outside whenever on
saturday sundays but i made it work
right and it's just an awful season
i don't know what the work's gonna be
for you and you know
the work might kill you you know hey now
honestly man i know you think cool cool
keep boundaries bro well at this job
that doesn't work and that might be the
case man so i trust you to make that
call
just don't be afraid of three or four
years of grinding 70-80 hour weeks that
give you a platform not only financially
but a platform of skills a platform of
strength a platform of resilience that
will allow you to do things
for the rest of your life sometimes it
takes four or five years to change a
family tree and this might be your
moment right thank you so much for the
call brother samuel we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in mls consumer access
dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane sweet 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to west
palm beach florida what's up carrie how
we doing
hey what's up dr john for having me on i
really appreciate it of course thank you
yes okay so um i am
that last call kind of gave me some good
insight in a way because i guess i can
relate in a lot of sense to that caller
but um what i'm really calling about is
my husband and i
we're not really sure if we want to have
kids anymore um and we know we don't
already have kids so we're not giving
them up
but i was like
this ought to be good we have a
and a nine-year-old i hate him
exactly yeah so basically what happened
is um like where i'm at is i know like
how hard it is for
a marriage to you know have a kid and
how many unknowns can be thrown at you i
mean i have a brother whose special
needs i watched all that unfold he's
12 years younger than me so you know i
know firsthand how difficult it can be
my husband's a really chill guy he's
kind of like
goes slow
um he's kind of okay either way if we
have kids or don't um so it feels like a
lot of it is on me
um he's kind of like you know if we do
it's a great adventure if we don't
pay more travel more dogs whatever so
basically
yeah dog dad whatever but uh not a thing
but keep going
so yeah the plan was really when we got
married and everything it was kind of
like all right we're gonna put ourselves
in the best position we can financially
all that kind of stuff
to you know set ourselves up to have
kids i really value and think it's
important for
the mom to stay home with the kids um
just because there's a lot of
i mean why have kids that they're going
to be shipped off to daycare i mean i
don't know if that sounds harsh but i
that's kind of what i think yeah most of
the show is pretty harsh so it's all
good
yeah so yeah kids i know in my brain i'm
like moms don't get enough credit i mean
their kids are a full-time job so i
think it's important for a parent to be
with them and so much developmental
you know things are happening when in
those first few years okay so i'm
in my head i'm kind of like i want to be
the one that you know leaves the ship on
that but you don't want to be the one
well the the problem is i mean yeah kind
of ice well so this is kind of like
release last caller a little bit i mean
i started making a lot of money and i
make a lot more than my husband so it's
a thing where
i'm not really
you know it's it's like we're on this
train we're building wealth we're doing
good we're on you know baby steps four
and six like just
doing well
and it feels like we're stopping
everything and i know it would be for
like a season
because you know like i said i want to
be full-time stay-at-home mom
and the plan was you know my husband
would have moved up in his career enough
but i'm like do i really want to live on
that income do
is he even that motivated to have kids
if he's not willing to
work all these extra hours you know like
you were saying to the last caller
um you know to save up and have because
is it really that important to him um i
think
you know he's in a good position in his
job and i think he's an extremely hard
worker i don't think he's slacking off
he's doing the best job he can and he is
doing well but it's just the career path
he's on is different than mine
um
so you
you know carrie this is not about kids
okay yeah i probably do this has nothing
to do with kids
you've created some stories in your head
about kids
and why kids are the epicenter of your
angst here but it's not kids
okay i think it's your marriage
and i think it's
yeah that is your marriage good
i feel like it's great i love my husband
i mean i don't have any the only
issue not even like you know issue is
just that i feel like the
this kid's thing is what's holding me
you know it's i mean i have so much fun
with him i never would have picked a
different guy i mean i
do not think that he's i think he's the
best
so i don't think it's really um
when you say it's a marriage thing i
mean like i said the only issue in our
marriage is this comes up and it's like
no solution no solution and but it's no
solution because y'all won't
neither one of you feel comfortable
stating out loud what you really believe
i don't believe for a second that he
doesn't have an opinion
not for one second i've been with the
most laid-back burnouts who i don't even
know that they have
like some of my closest friends man
smoke more weed than they eat food right
and
um
but they've got an opinion
and
i think deep down you have an opinion
and in a marriage where y'all can't say
those things out loud i always wonder
what else is there
what's unspoken
you know what i'm saying okay this is a
big secret that means something to both
of you
yeah
um i feel like i can talk to you about
anything i don't have any we have so
much good communication i mean i i
really am one of those people i don't
hold back i mean
but sometimes when
when someone who doesn't hold back is in
in a relationship with someone
else then that person
does a great job of creating boxes to
put their things in
so let me let me just ask you like um do
you want to have a kid
put all the other stuff aside put the
money stuff and you don't want to live
without you know whatever acromension
you don't want you don't want the
lifestyle that might come
with the boundary you put on yourself
and his income
so take that away
do you want to be a mom
yeah
like do you want to have a little
knuckleheaded carry crawling around
yeah
because if you want that then you figure
that out
there's been beautiful wonderful kids
born in all types of situations for
millennia
that doesn't seem to be the issue the
issue is a
there's something between
my again i i talked to you for three
seconds
it feels like hey if i do this if i make
this sacrifice then he's probably not
gonna uphold his end of the bargain to
keep this lifestyle that we got going am
i missing that because that's what it
sounds like
it well so like to me it feels wrong to
tell him
now now you're now you're like hedging
your relational bet right so you have
these feelings about him but i don't
want to tell him because that feels
wrong
well i've told him i mean i've said you
know
he says well you know
he's what do i want to do go get a sales
job or go to some other kind of you know
change his career entirely and i it's
one of those things where i don't want
to squash his dreams or to
do he has a little bit of a later start
in career-wise
mentally yeah but the
i mean part of me is like okay part of
me thinks you know if i don't do it in
the way that
i think makes the most sense i don't
know if i really want one or if i don't
know if he really wants one i mean he
like i said i really do believe that he
has
i get what you're saying he might have
opinion an opinion about it like not
might 100
100
100
i i'm not going to say my thing out loud
if i feel like
this is one of the first times i've been
on the show that this conversation would
be better in person you and me
just hanging out gotcha um
because i know like what i'm saying is
hard
you want to have a baby and either he
does or he doesn't
i don't think that's the issue
there is something about your lifestyle
that you have said and man have your
lifestyle that's great you get to choose
that if you come down and say my a new
kid is not worth driving a used car or
it's not getting a smaller home or
living in another neighborhood then yeah
don't have a kid okay
i
it feels like
you're worried about him stepping up or
filling a gap that it could be financial
but it could be so much more than that
tell me i'm wrong if i'm wrong i'm all
about being wrong
it seems like there's something bigger
about if i have a baby with this guy
something about this isn't going to work
i don't think it's that because i don't
think that he's one of those people like
i think he would be an amazing dab i
think he'd be amazing everything i have
a great like i said a great relationship
with him i i know what you're where
you're kind of getting at i mean like i
think some of this obviously is me and
my my past too and all that and like the
way i grew up and i'm trying to live you
know a better life and all that for my
future kids but
i don't think you know him as a person
is he's amazing person i have no qualms
about him being a good good guy he steps
up in ways that
you know he's an amazing partner with me
and partnership wise it's so that part
of it
you know i that's where i do feel like
maybe it is it maybe you are wrong quote
unquote but oh i'm dude i'm wrong all
the time trust me you're good okay so
let me ask you what is it then
it's it's so hard to say i just feel
like i don't
i don't i feel like i'm it's stopping
everything i mean like i said i don't
have a lifestyle that's not that's out
of control we have used cars we don't go
crazy on
you know
all this other stuff i mean we have we
live within our means we follow dave's
plan so
it's not like i'm giving up that i mean
i understand that it would be a season
of backing down and
letting us you know living on this
smaller income and all that and
or or
you've backed yourself into a corner
with like the
i don't want to just ship them off idea
there's a lot of gray area in between
there
there's a lot of i'm going to work part
time there's a lot of i'm going to work
part from home apart from there there's
a lot of
i'm going to
send to a tuesday thursday school to
right there's all kinds of things to a
full eight to five babysitter because
that's what it takes for us to stay
afloat in this where we live
to hey maybe we're going to move where
we live because we want to start a
family you've backed yourself into an
either or situation and those are always
dangerous
okay
and i'll even say if to stay afloat
you'll have a family and you have to go
to daycare you can still love your kids
deeply and wonderfully
okay
i just i don't know i know that um
because i've
been with those women and their kids i
know that
um but i also you're allowed with all of
your might to say no if i have a baby
i'm staying at home that's what has
appeared in that sentence there's a way
that's gonna be no ifs ands or buts and
that terrifies me
so
if your marriage is great
you do have to have that conversation
okay about hey hold on let's put it in
an envelope i'm gonna write down do i
want to have a kid or not and you put
one in yours and we're gonna seal them
and then we're gonna open them at the
same time like whatever you have to do
my gut tells me if he did not want to
have kids he would say i do not want to
if he did you're a
all all out all the time personality and
so it's best to hedge
yeah i mean it'd be cool it'd be a great
adventure or not like you know what i
mean
like i'm not gonna pressure you i love
you you're my wife whatever you think
um how much of this is that you're
terrified of
your little brother
yeah that's a lot of it too for sure say
that out later i wait the
more chances of
you know issues i mean my mom was an
older mom when she had my youngest
brother so it was like it's in my family
and it's you know so it's like that's
really scary carrie it's okay to love
your brother deeply
and to be terrified of that same outcome
for your kid
both can be true yeah
and special needs parents and special
needs brothers and sisters don't have
permission to say those things out loud
so i'm giving you that permission
probably wouldn't post it on instagram
you don't know what i mean
but that's something you can look at
your husband and hold his hands and look
him in the eye and say i'm scared that
this might happen
mm-hmm
yeah how to do that
but you set it up
maybe that's where
go ahead
yeah no maybe that's where too
i think he's he never had experience you
know with
um special needs kids and all that and
he i don't think he understood like how
even though my brother is mildly i mean
he has autism but it's like
that's not even a special needs thing
that's a big deal
no don't minimize it don't minimize it
it's hard it's hard yeah yeah i think he
saw that and was like whoa like this
could be our reality we have to take
care of him our entire lives he's never
going to live alone he may end up living
with us one day
so it's like he sees that for
you know future kids of us and obviously
nobody plans for that but i've i've
really stuck it in and said like
if we're gonna do this it's gonna be
we're going to do everything we can to
be super healthy and
you know best position but it's the
possibility still it's a possibility
walking across the street that you get
hit by a bus
yeah and we choose to
love deeply and recklessly what nobody
will tell you on this side of having a
kid having this side of having a kid
with special needs
is you find capacity your heart
triples in quadruples in size
it goes 100x in size 100 times its size
and it's really hard
and it's exhausting and you want to bang
your head against the wall and you love
deeper than most people walking to and
from dead-eyed in the grocery stores
that you will stand next to in the aisle
you have a capacity for love that nobody
will understand and you can't
here's what i'll tell you like my friend
the conversation with my friend john my
friend john's a couple years older than
me they had him and his wife jen had two
kids
relatively quickly in their marriage
and we used to hang out every monday
night me and him and todd every monday
night every monday night week after week
after week after week and then this baby
came along
and he quit wanting to hang out
i was like dude man and i
she's one of my best friends in the
world i blame jennifer i was like dude
man what kind of wife dude let him come
hang out
and it wasn't until i had my son
that maybe a year later me and john were
just having a drink and some chips and
queso at some place and
i was like dude why didn't you tell me
that you didn't want to hang out with us
because you got to sit on that couch
and hold that baby and he smiled at me
and he said because you would have
understood
it wouldn't have made sense
and so you can do all the math on this
side of it like yeah we're going to give
up our nights we'll be able to watch the
new series of dexter when it comes out
we're not going to be able to like go
out
yeah you can do that math and all that
math is true your life goes sideways
it goes crazy sideways your money goes
sideways
and
everything about
i can speak to me man everything about
me changed
everything about my friends who've had
kids they change is it always fun and
wonderful no it's crazy you do have to
be hyper intentional with your marriage
you do
and if you watched your parents marriage
slowly drift apart as parent as
marriages do especially with kids with
special needs you're gonna have to be
hyper intentioned about being a good um
a good co-captain of that ship and make
sure y'all take time for each other
but all the way back to this there's
some unspoken conversation unspoken
truth telling i think needs to happen
and you don't want to hurt his feelings
he doesn't want to hurt yours you'll
need to have that conversation where are
we and have a turn the lights on moment
when it comes to having kids let's just
have that moment okay
and
you said you want to have a baby
so if you do have a baby if you don't
be at peace with not
and be the best big sister that ever
lived be the best aunt that ever lived
is that fair
yeah
there's not a right or wrong here
there's not a right or wrong what i will
tell you is this
and this isn't scientific this is just
um
i've never heard
i've never heard the words uttered by
somebody who's
70 or older
i've never heard anybody utter the words
man you know what i wish i hadn't had
kids i've never heard those words
uttered
a couple of times i've heard 70 year old
and older folks say anne
i can't believe we didn't have kids
can't believe we didn't adopt kids we
were about to adopt and we didn't and
i've heard that before it's not data
it's not real that's just what i've
heard sitting with people at the end of
their lifespan
i don't know if that influences you one
way or the other but i can tell you this
trying to do math with love rarely works
you do math with your finances you do
math with your business but doing math
on the front end of love never works
so much deeper than you can possibly
imagine and messier and more
than you can ever imagine it's all of it
but in my life it's been super worth it
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month so decide to invest in
yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com deloney to get 10 off
that's betterhelp.com
all right one more let's go to jack in
indianapolis what's up jack
hey dr john thanks for taking my call
you got it brother what's up
so i really need your help with
something um
my question for you today is how can i
support my girlfriend with an eating
disorder
specifically she has bulimia okay and um
we've been dating for about nine months
i'm 30 years old she's 26
and she's loved my life i can't see a
future without her i want her to be my
wife future mother my kids and as we've
grown closer together
i learned that she suffered with an
eating disorder for about six years um
throughout high school and college and
um
you know she's done inpatient and
outpatient treatment
but i've noticed some evidence lately
that
she's been binging and purging what's
the evidence
um so
specifically one night
she had overeaten like a lot and
she went to the bathroom for a while and
she came out and her eyes were
really wet and there were like food
particles in the toilet okay and you
know i i it took me a second to realize
what that was
and then
my mind started looking back at things
in the past like oh she cancelled
several of our dates like we had plans i
wonder if she's staying home to binge
and purge
um
you know things like that there's i'm
kind of like looking at things that have
happened in the past and saying okay
there was evidence there for the eating
disorder and i just missed it okay or
maybe i didn't want to see it
and so now my mind is spiraling i'm kind
of projecting into the future like what
happens when she gets pregnant is that
gonna
impact
you know her body image and
exacerbate the eating disorder um
you know when's when she goes to grad
school this fall is the stress of that
gonna cause the eating disorder to flare
up
yeah and and she doesn't know that i
know um that i that i've seen this
evidence and i just i don't know how to
talk to her about it
i want to treat her with dignity and
respect yeah because i've suffered with
addiction too yeah um
i just i don't know what my role is
awesome well um
and your heart's gold brother and
that's hard
that one's hard
um but thank you for the call and man
this is such a huge deal i think it's
important for me to just tell you um
there are some stone cold experts in
this field and i'm not one of them okay
here's what i know about
most people don't know that anorexia
up until recently with the opioid stuff
and it may still be it may be neck and
neck
the single most lethal mental health
issue was anorexia eating disorders
um bulimia i think is a the stats are a
bit different um and somebody will
correct me if i'm wrong um they send me
a note here but
um
it really beats up your body
one of the cornerstones of bulimia is
shame
yes right and so the secret part
a doesn't surprise me at all and b
that feeds the machine
the secrets okay
and so the greatest gift you can give
her
is in a
in a season tell her what you just told
me
really you did a great job i love you i
see no future of mine without you in it
and
i have a past
i struggle from addiction
you have um
been so vulnerable and brave telling me
about your past struggles with um
purging
and i noticed it happen again
yeah how are you and we start there
and here's a couple of hard hard truths
here number one you can't heal her
number two you're going to want to look
for evidence of this everywhere and i
would recommend you not do that
okay okay she may have missed dates
because she had other things going on or
she had covet or she had the like who
knows what you know this one time and
maybe two or three other times you're
not telling me about but um
often we'll start to play beautiful mind
and we'll start to be like oh yeah and
then and then and then right and all of
a sudden we're on a youtube channel with
our conspiracy theory right
when it comes to relationships i would
just turn the light on on this one it's
hard
um
some studies show up to 50 of people who
struggle bulimia have a history of
anxiety
um the idea that it's all body image is
more media fabrication than reality
there's a mix of genetics here there's a
mix of um
anxiety there's even some some new stuff
out that it might be a metabolic issue
that a body just has a i don't really
know how to describe it but
a body has a tendency to run lower than
um a
physio neural body would do so
all i had to say is it's a complex web
of stuff
and
do may need to go back to counseling
right well no i won't say may she
probably 100 needs to
a great gift you could give her is i
want to come with you would you be
willing to go and i'd like to join you
um
there would be a connectivity there that
would be awesome okay
and this i love that idea this is such
as open to that okay here's the other
thing she may tell you you're i don't
even know what you're talking about how
dare you i can't believe you did this
and
here's one of these things to keep in
the back furthest reaches of your heart
okay
you may blow your relationship up and
save her life
okay
because she may tell you to go to hell
she may say screw this i'm not having
this conversation with you
okay and that will hurt more than
anything because you're coming to her
with an open heart and trying to look to
her future
um i would recommend
i'd stay away from like well what about
our unborn baby and what about i
wouldn't go down those roads okay those
are we're talking a couple years out
okay
um let's get to
i noticed some old patterns have shown
back up and i'm really scared and i've
been there too and i'm scared for you
i'm scared for us i'm scared for me
because i don't know how to love you
right now
but i see it and i'm willing to walk
alongside you because you and i have a
future together
um
but that starts with no more secrets
okay i love that idea okay
and hear me say this brother she is
lucky to have you
um
read less google okay
what's it called read less google don't
go
google this less is what i'm saying yes
i'm looking up every resource online
yeah i i would do that much less i would
talk to a professional um who's got
experience working with um
women in disorder eating it's hard it's
hard
there's just so much going on so much
going on so much going on um but again
she's lucky to have you my brother um
i'll say this out to everybody um
again i'm not an expert in this um
obviously working with
um high school and college students for
as long as i did i've seen it so often
it is very very hard so if you are
struggling with disorder eating
whether you are struggling with anorexia
and you're just not eating
you're binging and purging you're eating
too much
please
reach out and call somebody please reach
out and call somebody and if you love
somebody who's struggling from one of
these three evil iterations of distorted
eating
hold somebody's hand look them in the
eye and say i love you
i love you enough to say i see
that you're not okay
i love you and it's not about it's not
about i need to tell you that you're
beautiful i mean it's not it's it's so
much more complex
tell somebody you love them and you're
willing to walk alongside
the hell that it's going to be
to get to healing on the other side of
this thing we'll be right back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
and as we wrap up today's show
a little bit on the nose with the rage
rooms
but this rage against the machine and
they're classic
testify and it goes like this
the movie ran through me the glamour
subdue me the tabloid untie me i'm empty
please fill me mr anchor assure me that
baghdad is burning your voice is so
soothing the cunning mantra of killing i
need you my witness to dress up dress
this up so bloodless to numb me and
purge me now if thoughts of blaming you
yes the car is our wheelchair my witness
your coughing oily silence mocks the
legless ones who travel now in coffins
on the corner the jury's sleepless we
found your weakness it's right outside
the door now testify
that's what we do here on this show
man see you soon
coming up on the next episode and hey i
was just doing an interview and somebody
told me like dude you yell all the time
and i was like no i don't and i was like
oh my gosh i do
so hey everybody welcome to the dr john
delaney show i'm glad that you're here
my family has fallen apart and my life
is pretty much blown up here in the last
couple of weeks i screwed everything up
and i don't know what to do but before
you do anything else before you go down
the rabbit hole what i do i'll you have
to sit in it for a second and grieve
not liking my kids like i love them to
death but i'm finding myself in a place
where i'm
not liking them
not like sometimes but like majority of
the time thank you for
thank you for having the courage to say
that out loud good morning how you doing
today dr john we're figuring it out
figuring it out what's up same here
that's why i called you okay tell me
about it